[Music]
dave i'm seeing this all over social
media i don't know why but the young
people are gravitating towards these
universal life policies and here's how
it's marketed they go you know it you're
supposed to use your life insurance
while you're alive did you know that and
everyone's like oh my gosh this is
brilliant this investing policy inside
of my whole life oh my gosh this is
amazing i'm gonna become a millionaire
and the commissions and fees these guys
are making selling this crap is insane
and the amount of time you have to spend
pulling that premium every single month
in order to make any amount of money is
absurd well i don't know how it's legal
the indexed universal policy is um
it's a newer version of an old bad idea
is what it amounts to and so what you're
going to find if you take this product
apart and look at the components of it
the insurance portion goes up every year
it's basically what we call an art an
annual renewable term
term insurance all life insurance gets
more expensive every year that your life
period because you're statistically more
likely to die every year you're alive
right brilliant so if you're 51 you're
more likely to die statistically than if
you're 50.
period
okay end of story now why would you get
how do you get then a 15 or a 20-year
level term insurance well it is cheaper
than the average of the 15-year of
increases
the art would start out cheaper and it
would end higher and the lines would
cross right in the middle hypothetically
if it was exactly how you see what i'm
saying so the art would go
it'd go straight up and the 15 year
would be level and it would cross right
in the middle at seven and a half years
however it doesn't do that because it is
cheaper for an insurance company to
produce a 15-year policy that because
they keep you for 15 years then it's
called persistence in the insurance
business than it is for them to try to
get you to stay with a policy that goes
up every year can you imagine that if
you get a bill and every year it goes up
you're probably more likely to cancel
that so that policy doesn't stay on the
books so it's more expensive for them to
sell arts so net result is a 15 year is
way cheaper than the average of 15 years
of art
okay now the index universal goes up
every year inside the policy but you
don't see it
so if you got a 400 premium
a certain portion like on your you know
if you ever look at your mortgage your
mortgage payment a portion goes to
interest a portion goes to principal the
further you go along more goes to
principal less goes to interest this is
exactly the opposite the further you go
along more goes to insurance less goes
because the art is going up every year
inside there less is going to your
investments and so if you keep the
stupid thing long enough it will begin
to be the point that the premium you're
paying will not even cover the insurance
cost
and so it starts to eat back into your
savings just to keep the policy alive
and the thing gets what we call upside
down in the insurance business and so
now you've got a real piece of crap
that's that's eating itself from the
inside out but they pitch it as this
really sophisticated nuance listen it's
so complicated you don't understand just
trust me yeah as your insurance guy i'm
gonna make you lots of money let me give
you a clue okay when you drive past most
cities the skyline has banks
and life insurance companies
these are the two towers in every
skyline
santa claus didn't build those
and those people didn't build them with
wealth they inherited they built them
with money they took from you
banks
screwing you
life insurance companies
screwing you this has been going on for
decades nothing new it's not a new it's
not a new song not a new dance and just
because you put it on tick tock for
god's sakes doesn't make it smart matter
of fact that kind of dumbs it down
that's a trigger word for you i'm sorry
i shouldn't have mentioned anything i
mean it's just like what we teach is
that you should take the difference that
if you pay a five bucks per term life
versus 100 for whole life take the 95
bucks you would have spent and invest
that and you're gonna be way better off
than having touched one of these crappy
policies yeah oh here by the way after
you paid extra on this all these years
and you die
they only pay the face value
they don't pay the face value plus your
savings that you've been paying extra to
build so it's like a savings account
with a crummy rate of return
that gets lost when you die they keep
your money
i mean what who would bank with that oh
people that buy stuff on tick tock i
think danny needs better friends yeah
well it's time no i mean that happens to
everybody er
because that's how most
particularly whole life permanent life
crappy life insurance is sold is some
old friend from college suddenly
remembers you my buddy from northwestern
mutual said yeah
let's be done with that oh that's
horrible that happened to me that
happened to me i bought it we've all
been when i was a child boy yep i sure
did i did the same stupid stuff and i
have a degree in finance and i fell for
the call now he's a grown man america
he made it